[Musik]
Wir stiegen ins Auto und überquerten die Berge und Ebenen
darauf und
hin eigentlich
wir sind gegangen
Ein Besatzungsauto fuhr und ein Panzer stand
und wir erreichten den Kontrollpunkt und überlebten dort
echtes Verhör
das ist genau der Blockpfosten, den wir von Mariupol und
Ich kann sagen, dass ich persönlich erlebt habe
in der Tat solche Demütigungen ihrerseits
denn wenn sie nur mit dir reden
sehr so
wenn sie sagten, das Wort schwiele dich
demütigen Sie einfach nicht wissen
[Musik]
vom ersten Tag an habe ich das verstanden
Solche historisch wichtigen Ereignisse finden statt
Ereignisse, die ich einfach nicht kann
Ich weiß nicht, wie ich es nicht aufschreiben soll
Was übrigens in den Bedingungen, in denen wir waren
es war nur das Schreiben für mich
das verwandtste und das einfachste, weil
es ist nur Stift und Papier
24. Februar
Vor 2022 Jahren gab es keine Straße, wir haben sie beleuchtet
Die ganze Welt ist mit uns
Als nächstes habe ich eine kleine Liste, die ich
Ich wollte besuchen, wenn der Hashtag gewonnen hat
wollte es jetzt irgendwo laufen lassen
Ich möchte auch Hand anlegen
einen Rockclub in Lemberg zu besuchen
befindet sich in der Chernivtsi Straße und
Kharkiv dann wollte ich den Platz besuchen und
Philharmonie
wenn du jemals irgendwo einen Traum hattest
Es gab einige Podulisten, einige Tuzit a
jetzt ist es nur so, eh
dann gibt es keinen Platz zum Leben, um es aufzuschieben
Jetzt
[Musik]
etwa danach
Im 14. Jahr denke ich viel mehr
gerade in der Gesellschaft entstand so etwas
Interesse an dem, was ich im Allgemeinen bin
Mariupol in der Ukraine und was es ist
eigentlich das Mariupol-Gefühl der Ukraine
[Musik]
Der 20. März ist der heutige Geburtstag
Lordyka ist mein Hund
äh
Dieses Terrier-Kind hat ein wenig abgenommen, aber
Seine Nachbarn dankten ihm sehr
ein Stück Hähnchenbrust ist köstlich
Ich habe mein Frühstück gegessen und ich habe es immer noch hier
Rekord, dass Papa zu Oma ging, sagst du
in der Nähe des Meeres Hier kam ich mit einem anderen
auf Einladung der Nachbarn sind sie dran
zu sich nach Hause eingeladen, weil sie es wussten
dass wir im Zentrum sind. Dort ist es viel gefährlicher
weil alles durch dich fliegt und sie leben
am Meer und sie sagten nur
kommen Sie viel zu uns
leiser Ich habe mich noch nie so gefühlt
Stadt
sowohl in einer modernen Stadt als auch im 21. Jahrhundert
was sehr lebendig ist, ist sehr aktualisiert sehr
nur so pulsiert ich selbst noch nie
Ich fühlte mich nicht so, weißt du was
Steinzeit
wie damals Nun, das ist auch die Erfahrung aller Menschen
Weil
so etwas, dass Sie zunächst gut zu Ihnen
da muss man sich an einiges gewöhnen
dort können Sie automatisch das Badezimmer betreten
Fangen Sie an, den Wasserhahn dort und dann zu öffnen
Anna im Allgemeinen so schließen Sie es zurück und
Nun, wenn da nicht die erste Woche danach wäre, da war ein
dann hat jeder perfekt verstanden, was
Der Teufel nimmt mir den Schnee, er schmilzt nicht
Wohnung oder im Haus was soll ich wo machen
Ich musste Wasser finden und alles war mit allem
alles musste abgebaut werden, wenn das so war
Ich denke, es war
Darin sehe ich einen positiven Punkt
weil du alles gebraucht hast
wenn ja zu sagen, so zu tun
Jagd nach einer Ressource, weil Nun, zuallererst
so etwas macht dich sehr an
sozial und wenn es dein Ding ist
Tiere werden sehr stark einbezogen
Instinkt die Küste und Sie, wenn
Du fängst genau jetzt an. Nun, genau jetzt
eine Ressource irgendwie ursprünglich, direkt zu suchen
sehr viel von allen Seiten
warum waren wir davon nicht so beeindruckt?
sie sind schon irgendwie angekommen. Nun, ich weiß nicht
Das ist schon mal eine Art Erleichterung
Es war einfach unglaublich
Welche hast du aus deiner Region verlassen?
es ist dir passiert, nun, persönlich ist es mir passiert
Ich will nicht das von jemand anderem
Erlaube dir, so zu denken, aber
aufgrund dessen, was wir dort wirklich für Sie erlebt haben
Sie schmeißen dich einfach raus, du wirst die ganze Zeit rausgeschmissen
wird eine Konstante wie eine Art Landstreicher
auf dem Heimatland und
wenn nur
wir haben es schon gesehen, als wir gegangen sind
dass ich die Leute dort Zaporizhzhia uns nicht kenne
trafen übrigens Augen wieder
noch freiwillige Zelte
in dem man sich dort ausruhen kann
Sie müssen dort ein wenig essen und es herausfinden
einige Informationen durch Freiwillige über
Wohnung
es ist so direkt für mich
Ich war beeindruckt, dass es nur du warst, als es das erste Mal überhaupt war
Dieses Mal sah ich eine solche Sorge um die Menschen
nur von anderen Leuten und du verstehst
Was soll's, ich bin endlich zu Hause
endlich, erst jetzt habe ich es in mir
nur in seine Heimat
wenn du Pflege siehst und wenn du siehst
diese Verwandtschaft aller Menschen, die alle
einander helfen und das ist alles
Sie fühlen sich wie zu Hause
[Musik]
Lemberg ist für mich meine Stadt, ganz einfach
Stadt wo
Ich habe viele Freunde, ich habe viel
viele Verbindungen und deshalb sind wir als Eltern hier
[Musik]
wie ich mich mehr und sicherer fühle als
meine zweite Heimatstadt sein, das ist Lemberg
[Musik]
Du weißt, ich will es wirklich
Der Sieg war für alle Städte und somit für mich
Ich denke, wann
alle Städte, die jetzt vorübergehend sind
Blockaden oder besetzt, damit sie werden
[Musik]